a frico camp and welcome to another the
daily program or webseries video and in
this video we're going to talk about a
problem called spiral ascension which is
number three to zero so let's go ahead
and look at the problem and read it on
the subreddit alright so this is the
problem that we're going to be solving
in this video it's challenge number
three to zero it's called spiral
ascension and I'll go ahead and spray it
off says the user enters a number make a
spiral that begins with 1 and starts
from the top left going towards the
right and ends with a square of that
number so some examples they give you is
a 5 and if you see here you have a 2d a
grid or 2d array where you have it going
from 1 to 5 on the top row and it just
clockwise keeps counting up until you
reach the last number which is n times n
25 and then again another challenge and
input is 4 where you just print out this
grid down here so that's basically the
problem that we're trying to solve it's
super straightforward given one number
print out a grid that's n by n which
follows us like fashion right so the
hard part is trying to mimic that or how
do you kind of simulate that in the
computer so again let's go ahead and
define this problem on the whiteboard
before we break it down with my solution
ok so in this problem you're given an in
and using that in you're supposed to
build up an N by n matrix or grid in
this case we'll just say n is equal to 3
so if n is provided and it's 3 we need
to build a 3 by 3 grid and then the goal
is to print out a matrix with spirals in
this fashion so if you notice that the
Center number is just N squared and your
goal is to print out starting at one
going in a clockwise manner until you
reach the center all right so now that
we understand the problem that we're
trying to solve let's try to work it out
where n is equal to 3 so if you
takeaways is if n is equal to 3 we know
that we're going to keep putting values
until we reach the final value of n
squared which is 9 right so we know that
in our code we could just do some type
of loop and loop until our very
well suppressives X is created a nine
because nine of the last element we're
going to play so that's one takeaway
that we can kind of get from this
problem another takeaway is we need to
start in the top left corner so if we
were to represent the rows and the
columns as integers we know that the top
left corner is going to be zero zero so
we can go ahead and just place the first
value which is one in that top left
corner now the next part that you kind
of have to realize is you need to set
some type of direction so each iteration
we're going to be moving in a certain
direction either to the right down left
or up so in this case we're going to
represent that with a positive or
negative one and using the variables D
row or D column so for example if D Rho
is equal to one that means we need to
move in a down direction or if D Rho is
0 that means we don't move up or down
and instead of D column was set to 1
that means we need to move in the
positive right direction so D Rho and E
Kalla or the variables we're going to
use that kind of figure out the
direction in which we're going to move
and then also when we get to certain
spots we're going to move the direction
in a clockwise manner and if finally row
and column is the particular spot in the
matrix that we're at that current
iteration so working through this let's
go ahead and we put the first value of 1
in the row 0 column 0 and then we need
to check to see if the direction we're
about to move has an element or slot
that we can move to so if we do Rho Plus
D Rho which is 0 and then column plus D
column which makes column equal to 1 we
say is there an element here like is
this out of bounds or have we already
put something there and if so we need to
go ahead and change direction in this
case none of that is true there is a
blank slot there so we can move in that
direction so we can just go ahead and
increment the value of x - 2 and place
that 2 in whatever row and column
element that we're at that current part
of the iteration all right so now we
just do that again right we check
if we were to add D column to column in
D row to row would that put us in bounds
and in fact it would give us an element
that hasn't been seen yet so we can go
ahead and do that same operation where
we increment X we increment column by
adding D column to it so now we're at 0
2 and we can put it 3 there now for this
third iteration or the next iteration if
we were to move to 0 3 we'd be out of
bounds right so we know that we need to
move in a 90 degree clockwise fashion to
go down now so one thing to take away is
to kind of switch directions we can just
swap the values of D row and D column
right because we need to go down
positive 1
which means that D Rho will just become
whatever D column is and then D column
will just become whatever D Rho was and
we can negate it and I'll go over that
in a second when we get down to going
left so again we do the same process
where we add a D Rho 2 Rho which gives
us a 1 here we go ahead and increment X
we're at 1/2 place the value increment X
we're at 2 2 again and place the value
and then if we were to move in the same
direction one more time we go out of
bounds which means we need to do that
same operation where we switch these so
D Rho becomes 0 which would become the
value of whatever D column was D column
is going to be equal to what 0 was which
is 1
but then negate it which allows us to go
left so then in this case when we add D
column to column this will become 1
which puts a set a 6 same process this
becomes 0 this becomes 7
and again if we're to move in the
negative direction we go out of bounds
so we need to swap these again so zero
becomes a negative 1 negative 1 will
come 0 which if you look at this that
means that we're going to be going up
again we can increment the 7 here to an
8 and D row to row to make this a 1
instead of 2 and now we check if the
next element we're going to go to is
already existing we again just do the
whole swapping mechanism so this will
become positive 1 this will become a
zero increment this to a 9 and add D
column to column so we're left with 1 1
and we built up our grid and the same
process will work for bigger and bigger
grids
as long as you just keep checking if
you're about to go out of bounds or if
you're about to go to a slot that's
already has a value we just go ahead and
swap do your own D column and negate D
column add it to row and column place
the value and then increment X by 1 all
right so that's the solution on the
whiteboard let's go ahead and implement
this in JavaScript all right so start
off let's go ahead and create a function
called create grid which is going to
take one parameter called in which is
going to be how big are n by n a
sentient grid should be and I'll go
ahead and say constant grid is equal to
an empty array and then return that down
here and this will be the array or grid
that we're trying to build up and then
down here we'll go ahead and console.log
create a grid of 5 so we can kind of
work towards a solution using in a 5 so
the first step is we need to create a
invite in blank grid or array which I
found this little implementation on
Stack Overflow which can be used for
building up a n by n grid and all this
is doing is creating a grid that's in
and then for each element inside they're
putting another array which is links it
in so now that we have a blank 2x2 or M
by n grid we can go ahead start
those variables like we used on the wire
for example so starting off I can say
let numbers equal to 1 which is going to
be the first number that we start off
and it's also the X that we use in the
whiteboard we can say let Rho is equal
to 0 let column is equal to 0 which are
going to be used for representing
representing the exact element location
that we're at in the grid we can say let
D Rho is equal to 0 and let D column is
equal to 1 which is going to be the
initial direction which will be in the
right direction or going from left to
right that we need to traverse the grid
in so we've declared all of our kind of
starting initial variables are going to
use for the iteration the next step is
we need to loop X amount of times until
we reached in x in as our final final
number so if you remember we need to go
until number is less than or equal to n
times n so in the 3 by 3 example this
will go until we reached 10 or one more
than 9 so that should make sense as to
you know the while loop we're doing and
why we have to loop to n times in the
next step is we need to place our
current number inside the grid at the
current location that we're at so if we
say grid of row column is equal to
number that will place a 1 in the top
left spot and then we need to again
increment number by 1 so I'll go ahead
say number plus plus here and like we
talked about after we place a number we
need to check if the next location we're
going to is out of bounds so I can say
if column plus D column is equal to n
which means are we going out of bounds
on the right side of the grid I can say
if Rho Plus D Rho is equal to n meaning
are we about to go out of bounds on the
bottom of the grid so I can see if
column plus D column it's equal to
negative 1 that's check can you provide
to go out of bounds on the left side of
the grid and then finally we can say if
we've already seen the location that
we're about to go to so grid of Rho Plus
D Rho and then column of column Plus D
column
that's already defined this is where we
need to do our whole swapping logic or
you know turn by 90 degrees clockwise so
to do that what we can do is just
declare a tenth value instead of equal
to zero so we can set D column equal to
zero
actually sorry ii d column equal to the
temp of d row and then d row is going to
be equal to d column so the exact logic
that we did over there we just set the
row equal to d column we set D column
equal to d row negated but we need to
use this kind of temp variable to keep
track of it because we're going to
overwrite it on line 17 so we need to
bring in another constant called temp so
we don't overwrite and then lastly we
just need to increment row by the
direction of the row that we're trying
to go so row plus equals d row which
will increment our row in the correct
direction and then same thing with
column we can just a column plus equal D
column which will increment column in
the correct direction so that basically
wraps up implementing the solution it
did in the white board in JavaScript you
see here at the bottom of the console
log it's printing out the correct row
where it's all spiraling clot in a
clockwise fashion from 1 to n times pin
so if you notice it ends at 25 and the
end that we started with was 5 so 5
times 5 is 25 yeah so hopefully this one
wasn't too hard if you have your own
solution or you have any questions feel
free to pay something in the comment
section below
just a heads up the next one I'm going
to talk about is called talking clock
and that is number 3 to 1 and I'll put a
link to it in the bottom of the
description of this video so if you want
to work on that now and then in a couple
days I'm going to post a my solution to
that problem so just a heads up and
again be sure to LIKE and subscribe to
free code camp in this video if you
thought this is a good tutorial all
right stay tuned for the next video
thanks for watching